three days on a deserted white island
smolders covered in ash too dangerous to
return to the bodies of the victims lie
somewhere amidst the desolate
devastation the names and images of the
dead and at least nine missing continue
to emerge tourists and tour guides
parents and their children among the
number Jeff Hopkins and his daughter had
just bought in a boat to leave the
island when the volcano erupted
he helped tend to the injured everybody
was severely burned from you know every
every scale of of burns horrific burns
of people that were coming on beau and
people were you know just dealing with
that the some were screaming in pain
some were silent some were just clearly
shocked
thirty people are being treated in
hospitals across New Zealand many are so
severely burnt the authorities have
called for more donated skin
Queen Victoria Hospital in Sussex
pioneered burns treatments working with
injured pilots in World War two experts
here say chemicals in the volcanic gas
will have compounded the injuries and
the prognosis may not be good there's
not only the thermal burn to the skin
but there's a very important mixture of
hot acidic gases that get it healed by
the victims of that particular tragedy
and that has a very serious effect on
the body's physiology and being able to
sustain life through breathing see my
bones get all the way up at my arm
Polly Brooks suffered 45% burns when she
was caught up in the Bali bombing she
says such injuries can remain both
physically and psychologically traumatic
if you've got anything north of like
4050 percent burns quite often you might
be in a coma or you're in so much pain
literally you can't move you can't move
your arms or legs or anything like that
they're probably absolutely terrified if
I'm honest I remember being completely
scared at my mind before it's burnt I
had no idea what it meant to be burned
you know it's like a tiny little burn on
the stove you like sour but when you're
burnt all over it's like a skin just
melts off here and you have no idea at
that point how important your skin is
until you lose it it's not yet safe to
retrieve the victims left on white
island those fighting in a hospital may
have been the lucky ones but the road
ahead is likely to be long and hard
Helen Anne Smith Sky News